Let's play a game with
CuriousChimpanzee, who is a long time
viewer of the stream, and let's go for
it with 1e4.
Yeah, as Jan said, I thought it was
more than impressive.
Well, we have another chance to play an
Alapin, and we face d5.
So I remember that previously I've
played this line against Curious, so
let's see if he has picked up some of
the theory.
Of course, here we play e takes d5,
queen takes d5, and d4.
We've had this particular position
many, many times, highly, highly theoretical.
Black plays knight f6, which is the
main move, and of course, we respond by
developing our own knight, knight f3.
This is all theory, and here, black is
at a major crossroads.
There are four or so options that are
all worthy of attention, and one of
them is indeed knight to c6.
Now, Nc6 is probably the move that you
would be making if you were looking at
this for the first time from Black's perspective.
The drawback of Nc6 is that the bishop
on f8 remains locked behind the e7 pawn.
And according to the new Alep and
Chessable course, the best way to try
to punish the move Nc6 is precisely by
exploiting its principal drawback,
which is that when white plays DC,
black is unable to recapture on c5 with
the bishop.
And if black has to take on c5 with the
queen, then it gives white a bunch of
tempi that we can use to accelerate our development.
So the move here, according to the
chess book course, is pawn takes pawn.
Now of course, pawn takes pawn is a
move that you might be reluctant to
play because it allows black to trade
queens and force our king out into the
center at the cost of a pawn.
And you might also think that it's
quite easy to win the c5 pawn back, but
that couldn't be further from the truth.
So I am going to play dc, even though
I'm pretty rusty on the theory after
queen takes d1.
So if curious is intimately acquainted
with it, then, you know, then the
position is going to get sharp.
a5.
So a5 is a very understandable move.
He's preventing us from playing b4.
But that doesn't mean that we have to
part ways with the c5 pawn automatically.
In fact, we have many, many ways that
we can try to cling to that pawn.
We don't want to cling to it at the
cost of ruining our position.
We want to find some sort of middle ground.
And if we're giving that pawn away,
then we want to find a good reason to
give it away.
So what are the options for defending
this pawn straight away?
Well, one of them is to play bishop to e3.
But as you know from many openings, the
drawback of bishop e3 is that it runs
into this very annoying move knight to
g4 Why is night g4 annoying because
night g4 threatens to eliminate the
bishop from the board to ruin our pawn
structure And then once black pushes e6
we once again have the problem of that
pawn So the move h3 comes to mind as a
candidate move in order to meet e6 with
bishop e3 Unfortunately, Black can fly
through a different airport, Black can
play knight to d5, and it's essentially
the same effect, where this bishop is
destabilized, so I actually don't think
that we should go for that approach.
Now, a3, e6, b4 fails tactically,
because Black will play a, b, c, b, and
knight takes b4.
You should know this from, you know,
the Queen's Gambit and other openings
where you get this pawn, this type of
pawn that you're trying to defend.
So, I actually think we should take a
more indirect approach.
One of the drawbacks of the move a5 is
that it weakens the b5 square.
So you might say, okay, well then let's
play bishop b5.
But bishop b5 has limited value because
black can just play e6.
What I like is a very Alepyn-esque type
approach to this position that involves
trying to get the knight to b5.
And that seems very promising to me
because from b5, the knight will not
only be aiming at c7 but in the event
that black pushes the e pawn which is
very likely and let's play the move
knight a3 as i'm talking about it once
black plays e6 or e5 and we respond
with knight to b5 we can also stick the
knight onto d6 and what could happen
then is a situation where black takes
on d6 and we take back securing the
bishop pair and getting control of the
dark squares and Even if, in the
subsequent complications, black wins
that pawn on d6 back, I still think
that we're going to get the upper hand
in the resulting endgame.
So, knight a3 is a move that should be
on your radar if you're experienced in
the alepen.
I mean, we've had plenty of games where
I made this move in the middle game,
and it makes sometimes more sense to
people when there's a black queen on
d5, because then you can more clearly
see the effect of the move knight to b5.
But even without the queen, knight to
c7 is still very much a threat.
So knight a3 is a nice flexible move.
It's a developing move.
And we're kind of waiting for black to
put his cards on the table.
All right.
So it's a good sign that curious is
starting to think.
Well, if black had played the immediate
e6, then of course we would have played b4.
And that I think is one of the
theoretical lines.
I'll open up the Chessable course after
the game to check in on what the actual
main line is, according to the authors.
Knight to d5, okay.
So a very understandable move.
Black is trying to cover the c7 square.
But just like the bishop on e3 is quite
unstable, so is the knight on d5.
Now some of you might instinctively
want to play c4 or bishop to c4.
Both of which are reasonable moves.
I like bishop c4 more because it's a
developing move.
But the problem with bishop c4 is the
black can respond with e6 and defend
the knight and open up an attack on c5.
And in that subsequent position, we
actually could trade on d5 and play the
move bishop e3, and then we've
basically permanently secured our extra
pawn on c5.
So that's one option.
One option is absolutely to play bishop
c4 here and chase the knight away.
Of course, another option is to stick
to our guns and play knight b5.
And this one I like even more, because
knight b5 creates a very devious threat
of c4, as well as bishop c4.
And once this knight is dislodged,
white's knight travels to c7.
And it may seem like a case of
one-move-itis, like, oh, is this really
such a serious threat?
Well, it actually is a very serious
threat because in order to defend
against it, black has to make one of
several major concessions.
Black basically has to ruin either his
king safety by moving the king the
d-file or his ability to castle
queenside by moving the rook.
In either case black basically has to
waste a very valuable move just to
defend against the threat of knight c7.
King d8 okay and now that we have
induced this particular move our knight
on b5 is also just chilling.
We could also go at it from the other
side with knight to g5 and that's a
more common idea than you might think,
sticking the Knights on b5 and g5,
hitting the f7 and c7 squares.
So knight g5 is a very interesting approach.
Black will probably respond with knight
e5 in order to defend f7.
And if we play f4 there, ooh, then
Black could try to counter-attack our
Knight with h6.
I'll show that line after the game.
So that's one way we could play.
We could also play this more
straightforwardly, just developing the
Bishop with tempo, Bishop c4.
Looks like a great move as well.
I like Bishop c4.
I think it's simple and very strong,
solidifies our advantage.
Knight g5 is the move that you would
play if you wanted to win the game on
the spot.
So knight g5, knight e5, c4, b4.
I'm trying to calculate that line out.
It's a little bit hard to assess how
good that is for white, in contrast to
just the simpler Bishop c4.
Knight g5, very very tempting move,
let's go for it, let's go knight g5,
I'm going for the throat this game,
sorry curious, I'm going for the
throat, just intuitively this feels
like it has to be the right move, just
intuitively it feels like knight g5
squeezes the most out of the position,
and it's not such a big commitment, you
shouldn't think of a move like this
like a path of no return, okay it
doesn't work out, big deal, we're not
introducing any permanent weaknesses in
into our position, we're just creating
a threat, and knights, unlike pawns, do
move backwards.
Okay, and bishop e6 immediately
justifies our move, immediately,
because now we have the standing option
of taking on e6, and to say that it
ruins black's pawn structure is
basically to say nothing, it just
permanently destroys any semblance of
normalcy that black has within the pawn structure.
So I'm taking those doubled e-pawns any
day of the week, particularly
Wednesday, which it right now is at the
time of recording.
Now, if you're a pedant, then you might
say, well, I don't have to take on e6 immediately.
I can just sort of chill in this
position because the bishop's not going anywhere.
But that doesn't mean you always have
to do that.
Just because you don't have to rush a
move doesn't necessarily mean that you
shouldn't play it if you can avoid playing.
And I don't see a reason for us to keep
this knight on g5.
It's not doing all that much.
And we might save a tempo on a
different move, but I think we should
play it simple and just take on e6
while we have the chance.
So now we have a choice of different
squares for this bishop.
And it's pretty self-evident to me that
our next step involves bringing this
bishop out.
Now the pawn on e6 is now one of
Black's main weaknesses and we can
attack it in several different ways.
we can attack it from a rook that would
come to e1.
But I think I see an even more
effective way of really targeting this
pawn and solving several problems at
once, which is a relatively
unconventional form of development,
which is why I think some people might
struggle to visualize this idea.
It might not occur naturally to you.
And yet I think it's quite strong.
Now, yeah, to get the Bishop onto like
either the h3 or g4 square.
So there's two ways to do it.
You can play bishop e2, bishop g4,
which is excellent, or you could play
g3, bishop h3, which I call the hyper
fianchetto because, you know, you're,
you're moving the bishop in that
direction, but you're not fianchettoing it.
Both options are totally viable, but I
like the look of g3 just because it's a
little bit more elegant.
Yeah, let's go g3.
What about c4 to fork?
Well, remember that the C7 square is
already protected by Black's king.
So we no longer are aiming for the fork
on C7.
Okay, well now we follow up with our
plan, Bishop h3.
By the way, if you really look at deep
positional play, you sometimes see
people, especially strong GMs, play h4
in these types of situations in order
to optimize the king side pawn
structure and to potentially be able to
use that pawn as a battering ram later
in the game.
Here, we have bigger fish to fry, and
we have an opportunity to really go
after black in the center before he's
completed his development.
So it's much more important to play
concretely than it is to make these,
you know, beautifying positional moves.
Now the move E5 has a very obvious
drawback, which is that the knight on
D5 has now lost its support, and the
idea, I use this phrase very sparingly,
but it essentially plays itself.
We want to put a rook on D1.
We don't want to attack this Knight in
any random way, right?
If you play Bishop e6, the Knight can
easily drop back, let's say, to c7.
And what have we achieved?
So instead, we need to move this King
out of d1.
We can move it to the c-file, we could
move it to the e-file.
It really doesn't matter all that much.
I like keeping the King closer to the
center in the endgame.
Also, you should notice the role that
our pawns are playing in restricting
the mobility, heavily restricting the
mobility of both of Black's Knights.
In particular, the d4 square is
covered, the b4 and f4 squares are also
covered, which was one of the major
appeals of playing g3 as opposed to
bishop e2, bishop g4.
Now we have a devastating threat of
rook d1, and I think black might be
borderline dead lost here.
And it's not just because we have an
extra pawn, it's because black's
position is completely in shambles.
And rook to d1, I don't think black has
a good answer to it.
He can't castle, right?
The King has already moved.
I think the only...
King e8, Rook d1.
Black can try to defend the Knight with
Rook d8, but we can still play Rook
takes d5 there.
Rook takes d5 and it's a classic trick
with Knight coming to c7 and picking up
the Rook again.
No, it's lost.
Black is totally dead here.
That's how quickly this endgame can go
bad for Black when you start making
these concessions.
Yeah, King e8, rook d1, and then the
knight can't move because of knight c7.
Yeah, e6 might be the only move.
e6 might be the only move here, in
order to gain a little bit of breathing
room for black's pieces.
Of course, in the event of e6, we will
take on e6, and essentially black can
resign there as well.
What's the issue with knight f6?
Well, then we give a check on d1.
The king is forced to slide over to e8.
Remember, that's partially why we put
the bishop on h3.
It wasn't just to attack e6, it was so
that when black played e5 we're also
containing the king and preventing it
from moving to c8.
So knight f6, rook d1, king e8, knight
c7, and the game is over.
When did he become so lost?
Well, first of all, this endgame is
better for I'm pretty confident that
according to modern theory, this is not
the best choice for black That's why
you don't see a lot of top GMs going
for the two Knights variation with
Knight f6 96 Okay kudos to to chimp for
for finding e6 Obviously, we don't need
to spend any extra time here.
We can just grab this pawn.
It's a very low risk move So these
types of moves can be made very quickly
Now, the knight now has a big problem,
because if it drops back to c7, then we
deliver a check on d1, we force the
king away, and we win the knight.
And then there's checkmate to follow
with the other bishop coming out to g5.
If black drops back the other way,
knight f6 is probably the only way to
keep the game going, would be my guess.
I think knight f6 is the only way to
stave off immediate defeat.
And then we'll think, I mean, maybe
bishop g5, maybe rook d1 check, lots of
candidate moves there that all should
win the game.
Knight c7 played, yeah, well, this is
just gonna lose.
Rook d1 check, king e7, and we collect
the knight, and simultaneously deliver
checkmate on g5.
GG.
Obviously a short game, but an
instructive one nonetheless from a
theoretical standpoint, because it
shows you dangerous this endgame is for Black.
Even though White's king to begin the
endgame is less safe, it's very hard
for Black to win this pawn back on c5.
So I'll show you a couple of important
theoretical lines, definitely a line
that you can play with Black if you're
very well versed in The position after
Nf3, in terms of popularity at like the
over-the-board level, Bg4 and e6
outweigh Nc6 in popularity.
Bg4 is by far the most popular move.
Here there's Bb2 and Nbd2.
There's even Ptxc5 here, which has
become very popular recently.
So even here, Ptxp is a move.
And what's funny is that in this
position, Black plays e5, and
historically this has considered a bad
line for white but recently some GMs
have breathed new life into the
position because in this position it
turns out that white can still play b4
and this is a trick that you should be
very familiar with this does not lose a
piece for white because white can
counter attack the bishop and basically
drive it out of its pinning position
which occurs in many many different
openings bishop h5 you play g4 now the
funny is, in order to garner the
maximum amount of pawns, black very
often plays knight takes g4 in these
types of positions.
But it turns out that white is the one
who gains a big initiative.
So here the line goes HG bishop takes
g4, and what is the best way to solve
the problem of the knight?
Well basically you want to avoid
allowing bishop takes f3, because that
forks the king and the rook.
So the move here is knight b to d2.
You're essentially forcing black to
recapture on f3 with a pawn, which puts
an end to black's initiative on the
king side, and then it's white's turn
to seize the initiative by completing
our development quickly.
And you can do that in several
different ways.
I think knight to c4 is considered to
be a really good move here.
And black is just really badly developed.
Technically both sides only have one
piece developed, but white's
development proceeds more naturally.
and it's quite easy to win this f3 pawn
back it's an unorthodox structure it's
a hard position to understand after
knight c6 the best move is bishop h3
and the point is that after the trade
after the trade um we're gonna win the
f3 pawn back and we're gonna have this
massive massive pawn failings on the
queen side that can often decide the
game because a well-timed b5 can send
this knight away and then you could
quickly push c6 and create a passer so
black is also having a lot of
difficulties finding sort of suitable
employment for the bishop now so this
line has suddenly become very popular
so bishop g4 is one option e6 is
another option and here our move is
knight a3 I think we've already had a
game in the speedrun with this line and
again same idea as we carried out in
the game after cd4 the point is we play
Knight to be five, and we threaten the
fork on c7, gaining a tempo, gaining a tempo,
and Black typically plays Queen back to
d8 or Knight out to a6 to protect c7.
And then I think White has a modest but
stable advantage.
If Black plays Queen to d8, then we can
play Queen takes d4 and go for a
slightly better endgame, or we can take
back with a Knight, and White just has
slightly more pleasant development here.
There's nothing major to say about the
position like this.
There's a lot of theory here.
Lots of GM games.
But this position is quite approachable.
It's easy to play, even if you don't
have like, encyclopedic knowledge of
the position.
The main move is actually knight b
takes d4, but the engine move, and the
way to get the biggest advantage after
queen to d8 is in fact queen takes d4.
And then if black plays queen takes d4,
it's already plus minus.
This endgame is incredibly nasty for
Black, for much the same reason that
the endgame we had in the game was nasty.
Black has no good way to defend the c7
square, because the move knight a6, as
tempting as it is, it basically freezes
Black's situation on the queenside.
Black now has no clear way to deploy
the knight.
Black has to keep an eye on the c7 square.
The bishop on c8 is locked out behind
his pawns.
So it should be visually apparent to
you that this is a pretty bad endgame.
For example, let's say Bishop f4, Black
plays Bishop d7, and White just
continues developing.
No need to do anything drastic here,
just play Bishop e2.
There are two games in the database,
both of them continued Knight d5, and
in both of them, White got impatient
and basically cashed his chips in for
the Bishop pair and played Knight d6.
Of course, this keeps a big advantage,
but the engine just likes keeping the
tension of Bg3.
The engine just likes keeping the
tension of Bg3, it's plus two.
So let's say Be7, Black develops, right?
Hopefully, I'm making a reasonable move
so far.
Castle's queenside, continuing the development.
Let's say Black Castle's kingside.
Funny line, if Black Castle's
queenside, if Black Castle's queenside,
he gets checkmated on a7, which is a
worthy mating construction to be aware of.
But if Black castles King's side, we
make this simple, improving move,
Bishop f3, then we bring the rook to e1.
And again, you might be surprised that
it's plus two, that's a pretty drastic
evaluation, but it really is that good.
Just compare the placement of the
pieces and you will see that Black's
position is not only miserable, but
very hard to play.
Because Black is running out of useful moves.
This rook can't move because a7 hangs.
The other rook can move to d8, and our
R rook moves into e1, and bishop takes
d5 as a threat.
And we could also reposition the king
on a safer square, on b1.
So just very, very unpleasant, annoying
endgame for black.
That's why knight a6 is the choice of
more top GMs here.
But it doesn't fully solve black's problems.
I won a recent game here over the board.
You play knight b takes d4, so in this
situation you don't recapture with the
queen, you recapture with the knight.
And again it's not easy to play.
Bishop e7, most popular move, and you
just develop your pieces, bishop e2.
You just develop your pieces, castles,
castles, and as usual, if black ever
plays e5, white's response is always
going to be the same.
If black ever plays e5, your knight
goes back to b5, and again you get the
situation where the knight on a6 is
essentially out of commission, and now
the pawn on e5 is another additional
weakness that black has be saddled with.
Hopefully this is making sense, just a
little bit of an overview of the main lines.
Now let's get to the move that happened
in the game, knight to c6.
So d takes c5 is far from the only
move, although it is the engine's
choice at a very high depth.
So let's get straight to that move.
Now it should be pointed out that queen
takes c5 does not solve black's problems.
As I pointed out, this gives white
rapid development and here the best
move is actually not Bishop e3, even
though I said it during the game.
I forgot the best move yet again, yet
again, is to play the immediate Knight
a3 heading straight for b5.
Black can lose this really, really
quickly if he's not careful.
So a couple of illustrative lines,
let's say Black plays e6, then our
Knight jumps into b5 and already Black
is in big trouble because if Black
plays Knight to d5, then white wins on
the spot with the move c4.
Same concept as in the game because
we're threatening the knight on d5 and
if black counterattacks remember that
you're also hitting the other knight so
here you win on the spot.
So black has to make a super awkward
move and kind of contort himself in
order to defend the c7 square upon
which we can play queen a4 and bring
the queen out and Black can't go here
because of the fork.
So constantly Black is stumbling on his
own feet here because of how cramped
the position is.
And after a6, Bf4, the game is over
because we have too many threats, Nc7
and Nd6.
So this is a already very nasty position.
If Black plays a6 in order to protect
the b5 square, This is a very common situation.
B5 is protected, but now C4 is
incredibly weak.
So now we can go Bishop e3.
Let's say the Queen swings over to h5.
Now we can play Knight c4 and our
Knight is heading for b6.
Again, this is very, very juicy.
So no matter how you slice it, and you
can look at this on your own a little
bit more, there is also the move e5
here, which is a little bit more
ambitious than e6, it happens pretty often.
We play knight b5 a lot of GM games
here Queen e7.
This is one of the main lines and Here
according to the engine white is
slightly better But more importantly
the position is very easy to play you
play bishop e3 and if black plays a6
Your response here is always going to
be the same queen to a4 Very important
resource that pins the pawn to the rook
and you might say well Why is that
dangerous black can just move the rook
well if black moves the rook you
actually castle queen side And this is
the line I show to anybody who says the
elephant is a boring opening.
You sac the knight on b5 in order to
get rapid development and a huge attack.
Bishop takes b5, Bishop d7, defending
the knight.
And of course, you make a very calm
move, very important, just because
you've sacrificed a piece doesn't mean
that every subsequent move has to be a
sacrifice or has to be something forcing.
You just bring your other rook into the
game and that extra piece is the
difference between Success and failure
and the attack black is paralyzed black
has no moves Let's say the black tries
to bring his bishop out with g6.
Well now it's time for more tactics
Knight takes e5 bang Knight takes e5
and now bishop g5 creating another pin
Creating another pin and your pieces
are all just I mean you're just gonna
massacre black here in the center And
then after Bg7, you have two pins, this
is one, and this is the other.
So both of black's knights are pinned,
which means you have Rxd7 winning the game.
Really, really pretty line.
Knight takes d7, and bishop takes d7 check.
And then and only then do you recapture
the queen.
So it's a cool line, and it gives you a
sense of how promising this can be.
And that's why I think King takes d1 is
really the only viable continuation for
black from a practical standpoint.
And here we get into some very
theoretical waters.
I don't want to bog you down with too
much exposition of the theory because
you can study it yourself.
And, you know, I know that a lot of
newer players are watching me, so it's
probably boring as it is.
I'll just give you a sense of what the
main lines are and why black
experiences problems.
So, on chess space, the main move is
e5, and it's closely followed by Bg4.
I actually think a5 is not a bad move.
It's been played, but it does, you
know, it gives white a very hefty advantage.
And my response, by the way, Na3 is not best.
Apparently, after a5, the best move is,
in fact, to play the simple Bb5, and
then to meet Bd7, just sort of standard play.
The engine actually likes ah, okay.
Okay.
There's a detail that I missed
according to the engine you go rookie
one E6 Bishop e3 and 95 it turns out is
not very scary because you can just
park the bishop on d4 So this is an
important detail you can put the bishop
on d4 and if black ever takes it Then
of course, you can rectify your pawn
structure by taking back with a C pawn
and now you're just up a full pawn so
Yeah, but I still think after knight
a3, it's all about the practical
difficulty of playing a position like this.
I think black's position becomes very
difficult to play just because you have
so many holes, and you have to be ultra
precise in order to keep everything secure.
So instead, the two most popular moves
are e5 and bishop g4.
In response to e5, white of course
plays b4.
And this is already very, very unpleasant.
If black plays e4, then you can always
swing the knight into the square that
is now open, the d4 square.
So the most popular move here after b4
is bishop f5.
But bishop f5, okay, it's not
particularly dangerous, you can just
play bishop e3, which is the best move.
And if black castles queenside, then
your king slides over to c1, which is a
very safe square, and it's already plus minus.
We're following a grandmaster game
here, Barylovich against Moisenko from
2007, and the best move here is just to
bring the other bishop out to B5.
You are not afraid of allowing Nxc3,
because you're a pawn up, and again,
Black is experiencing major problems
with finding a suitable developing
square for the bishop.
There's also a Gawain-Jones game here,
titled Arena on Leech as well, so White
actually played a lot of theory here in
a bullet game.
f6 is what happened and now white can
improve the placement of our king with
King b2 then you can play Knight bd2
rook d1 again black has no compensation
for the pawn and remember that anytime
black tries to cut into the pawn chain
you can always just play a3 once
black's rook leaves a8 you can just
meet a5 with a3 so that's one line the
other move that occurs very often is
Bishop to g4.
This would probably be my choice if I
knew nothing about the position.
Here you take the opportunity to bring
your Bishop out to e3.
Now the main move is knight to e5, as
we discussed during the game.
And the engine move is bishop c4.
This is kind of sort of an engine-y
line that is worth just memorizing,
because it turns out that after knight
takes e3, f takes e3, white's play
hinges on a very subtlety, which is
that after e5 you do not play b4 in
this position.
The reason b4 is bad is because after
e4 h3 we had a very similar position
where White's bishop was still on f1.
What's the chief difference?
Well the chief difference is that now
black can play f takes g2 and this is
very very unpleasant.
This gives black additional tempe that
he can use.
Black is here.
Instead what you do here is you play
the immediate h3.
You sacrifice the c5 pawn back.
Now it looks like black takes it and
black is completely fine, but
appearances are misleading.
I analyze this position and white is
significantly better here.
This can be a little bit hard to explain.
It's about plus over minus.
It's 0.7 in this position.
And I would say there's three reasons
that white is better in this position.
The first is white's control over light
squares is more meaningful than black's
control over dark squares.
Notice that a lot of the critical
important squares in the center are all
light squares.
Whereas black's bishop is sort of
biting on granite on E3, and white's
king is a very reliable defender.
Yeah, E3 is technically a weakness, but
black cannot reinforce the pressure on
that pawn.
Reason number two is that white's pawn
majority is more mobile than Black's
pawn majority.
Comparing pawn majorities is a very
good way of understanding the position
at a deeper level.
White is a 3 on 2.
Black is a 4 on 3, but that doesn't matter.
What matters is that White's pawns are
already ready to rumble forward B4, A4,
A5, and if Black plays A5, then he
creates a gaping weakness on B5.
On the other hand, Black's pawn
majority doesn't roll forward very easily.
Black can play F5, But black can't
create a passed pawn very easily, and
black's pawn movements aren't very meaningful.
The third reason is that white's knight
has better prospects than its counterpart.
Notice that black's knight on c6 is
completely restricted by these two
pawns, highlighted in yellow.
They're controlling all of the knight's
potential advancing squares.
White's knight has many different paths
that it can take.
In particular, it has very easy access
to the e4 square, and later on in the
game could potentially access the
outpost on d5.
So that is, in sort of verbally, why
white is better.
Now, how is the game likely to unfold?
Well, if black plays f5, then the
engine move here actually is
immediately to start pushing the pawns
forward with a4.
Black plays, let's say, rook d8, for
example, right?
Just making neutral moves.
And b4, you just start grabbing space
and pushing black's bishop away and
pieces away.
And now a5.
A lot of people, newer players, would
be tempted to go B5.
Who can tell me why this is a bad move?
And if you're watching on YouTube and
you're sort of newer to chess and
you're a little bit lost, this is a
good opportunity to review some of the
positional basics.
Why is B5 bad, but A5 is good?
Yeah, it's because of Knight A5, and
what's happened is that you have
allowed Black to establish a complete
blockade on the dark squares, and
because you don't have a dark squared
bishop, your pawns are now fully paralyzed.
So don't get blockaded like that, push
the other pawn first, now you're trying
to go a6 in order to soften up Black's
knight on c6.
Now I hope my explanations earlier were
somewhat understandable.
And this is a type of position that
occurred in one of the Nepo Ding games
where Black is now saddled with
permanent weaknesses of his pawns.
And White's knight potentially has
access to c5.
And Black can't castle because White's
controlling the light squares.
So, you know, it's, it's good not to be
dismissive and just say, Oh, this is
too much for me to understand.
I'm too new to chess.
You can understand how such positions operate.
And that is exactly how you learn about
positional chess, how you learn about
maneuvering play and where pieces belong.
It's by analyzing end games like this one.
But the bottom line here is that you do
sometimes sacrifice the C5 pawn back in
order to gain certain positional assets.
In this case, to reclaim the bishop
pair and to gain control over the light squares.
By the way, if after h3, black refuses
to take the knight, if black refuses to
take the knight, the move here, just a
moment, what is the move here?
Oh, it's just g4, bishop g6.
And actually you go king-y2, so you
still give the pawn back, and then you
go after black's bishop with knight h4.
and then you bring the other knight
out, and again, your control over the
light squares, as well as the prospect
of pushing your queenside pawns, gives
white an advantage here, despite appearances.
By appearance, this should be equal,
but because of these weak squares,
white is actually better here.
So very instructive positional ideas
here on top of the sort of specifics of
the variation.
Last thing I would say is that you
should not be afraid of getting your
kingside pawn structure ruined, because
here you also get the bishop And white,
black has no easy path to reclaiming
the c5 pawn, because you can always
reinforce it with b4.
And so I would say that black is in a
lot of practical trouble in this endgame.
Of course, if black plays knight e4,
trying to fork these two pawns, you
have bishop e3, and this is why this
line works concretely.
You have this bishop e3 move to support
both pawns at once.
So in any case, a5, knight a3 is not
the most precise move, and the reason
apparently, well white is still better.
Apparently bishop g4 chimp is the best
move here.
Just quickly prioritizing development
rather than trying to sort of
artificially defend the c7 square.
The problem with your move is that the
knight is very unstable here.
That's like the bottom line problem
with knight t5.
The knight is very easy to kick out.
I would argue that after Nb5, Black is
already completely lost, unfortunately.
Just because you're suffering on all
these squares.
Yeah, so Nd5, Nb5, you're in big trouble.
You have to get your pieces out.
Because that's the only way to
compensate for the loss of a pawn.
And the thing is, at this point, I
would not play Nb5.
Because this would run right into
Castle's queenside, and now the Knight
looks kind of useless.
Now the Knight looks kind of useless.
So, after bishop g4, I probably would
have played bishop e3, or something of
that nature.
And if black castles, I would have just
shifted the king around, let's say, to e1.
And the game continues.
Black has some activity here.
I think white is clearly better,
insufficient compensation, but you can
continue playing.
So something like this is what I would
do with black.
I would play bishop g4.
If black plays e5, then white's idea
works like a charm.
here you play Nb5, and obviously black
is no easy way to defend against Nc7,
this is the main idea.
So, Nc5, Nb5, Kd8 I think is, I'm not
going to say forced, but I don't see
any other reasonable move here, and now
I attack you from the other side, Ng5.
I think that your only chance to stay
in the game would have been to play Nc5.
I'm curious if you consider this move,
Because after Bishop e6 happens, I
think the weaknesses of your center is
just too much.
It's plus six after 96.
So 95 only move to stay in the game.
Of course, White has f4, and now you
have h6.
So this is one way to not give up f7
with a fork.
But of course, White is still winning.
And the simplest approach for White
here is just to grab the second pawn,
just to grab the second pawn.
And things are made even worse for
black by the fact that e6 is now
completely impossible, because the
knight will always hop into d6.
Maybe rook h5 can be tried here, but
white can reinforce the bishop with h4.
Another annoying detail.
And f6 we can develop with tempo like this.
So just not good, not good for black.
But perhaps the game could have
continued a little bit longer.
After you play bishop e6, and I play
g3, the game is over.
You just have too many weaknesses.
This is coming out.
Black is paralyzed.
You're not getting your bishop out.
You tried your best.
Your g6 was good.
E5.
I mean, you played reasonably, but I
mean, the avalanche is just falling on
black here, and you've got no
coordination, no development.
So the biggest mistake, the chief
culprit, of course, going into the end
game was one thing, but this 95 move, right?
When you're a pawn down in a situation
and you've got a lot of weaknesses,
generally prioritizing your
development, prioritizing active
development is the only way forward.
If you try to kind of bandage up your
weaknesses and put band-aids over all
the weak squares, something's going to
give because you just don't have enough
firepower to keep your pieces where
they belong, if that makes sense.
And this is exactly what happened here.
You just start collapsing because you
just don't have the activity to keep
your knight firmly entrenched on d5 I'm
threatening c4 I'm threatening this you
know you've got problems on the d file
and so that's what tends to happen when
you try to play a little bit too
passively from a defensive side when
you're when you're in this type of
situation so a nice al open game thank
you Jim for for playing I appreciate ob
you enjoyed the game a shorter one but
I still hope you found the opening
exposition to be relatively instructive
again the point is so that you're able
to watch speedrun videos and actually
play the opening yourself so this kind
of doubles as an opening tutorial even
though we don't cover all that much in
the grand scheme of things in every
game but still i mean hopefully you get
a sense of what people actually tend to
play and so on that note i'm going to
call it a night because i want to get
my seven hours in before arena kings
tomorrow which i will be streaming in
russian thank you everybody Lovely
Blitz session today once again.
Hope you enjoyed it and I'll see you
guys tomorrow.
Bye